besonders die gastronomie die ja jetzt
auch schließen musste alle kaffees alle
restaurants sind dicht spätestens seit
montag das einzige was noch geht ist to
go und ist der lieferservice wie
funktioniert aber eigentlich die essens
auslieferung in zeiten von corona wir
haben es uns angeschaut
mittags in hamburg tami ist unterwegs
die 24 jährige arbeitet für einen pizza
lieferdienste und fährt auch in corona
zeiten essen mit dem rad zu den
hungrigen kunden nach hause
es ist definitiv entspannter unterwegs
zu sein die stadt ist weitaus leerer als
sonst
sowohl was autofahrer als auch
fahrradfahrer angeht man kommt einfacher
und schneller zum kunden und wieder
zurück zum namen doch es hat sich noch
mehr verändert jetzt wird ganz besonders
auf gesundheitliche sicherheit geachtet
der kunde bestellt online bezahlt auch
online via paypal oder kreditkarte
kartenzahlungen bargeld nehmen wir
leider nicht mehr an
aber verständlicherweise die meisten
haben auch verständnis dafür nicht mehr
die bezahlung sondern auch die lieferung
ist kontaktlos meistens wird sie vor der
tür abgegeben manch einer gibt aber auch
einen besonderen liefert dann irgendwie
dass ein schuhregal vor der tür stehen
hat oder vielleicht selber schon hocker
bereitgestellt hat ich klinge stelle die
pizzen ab und entfernen nicht so zwei
drei meter von von der bestellung und
stellt dann auch noch sicher dass der
kunde auch wirklich die pizza
entgegennimmt und wie kommt der neue
service ist beim kunden an
ja die fand ich super da fühlt man sich
ja ganz sicher genau doch was ist auf
eine schöne alternative man wenn man
genau die tür aufmacht und die person
dann ein bisschen weiter weg ist und
dann genau die pizzen dann sozusagen
abholen kann aber hat sich der verstell
verhalten der menschen denn verändert
unter der klar geht es halt zurück
dadurch dass büros im home office sind
dennoch haben wir arbeit auch genügend
arbeit